also here tonight ben shapiro author of
the right side of history which many
people say was better than my book uh i
just i just don't agree with them but
that's i'll just let that stand all
right ben shapiro you've been watching
this case develop uh your thoughts on
the media coverage and this
runaway prosecutor
uh the media coverage has been
disgusting from beginning to end it
mirrored an original narrative which the
kyle rittenhouse must have been some
sort of white supremacist trump
supporter this is in the middle of the
riots in 2020 when we were learning that
america was apparently broken down into
two groups people who wanted racial
justice and people who supported trump
and you're on one side or the other
therefore if there were people rioting
in kenosha they weren't really riots
they were just mostly peaceful protests
and anybody who was opposing those folks
had to be some sort of white supremacist
trump supporter i mean you had joe biden
literally feature kyle rittenhouse in an
ad in september of 2020 alongside white
supremacist and as it turns out none of
the facts reflect any of that the only
people who got shot here were white the
people who were attacking him
at least one of them was a child
molester a convicted child molester
another another one of them was a
convicted criminal and uh and all three
of the people who were shot by kyle
rittenhouse were in the process of
attacking him by all witness forensic
and video video evidence so the media
completely botched this one and it is
just once more a reinforcement of the
fact that the media are a bunch of lying
hacks you do democratic party propaganda
for a living i couldn't agree more you
you mentioned i guess it was too complex
for the media to wrap their head around
the fact that there are white americans
who want to
want racial justice in this country want
the laws followed want police to conduct
themselves honorably but also don't want
their own hometowns
looted and ransacked and they couldn't
they couldn't really process that so
what they did is you mentioned they take
a convicted pedophile a lying communist
a guy who slapped his own grandmother
with an open hand and they made these
guys into heroes what does that say to
you about the press in this country
where those guys are the heroes in their
plot line
now the narrative matters much more than
the facts how many stories do we have to
see them botch in one direction before
we decide that they are just
propagandists i mean everything from
justice kavanaugh to the the covington
catholic case to justice malay to to
this they just keep botching story after
story but it's always in one direction
the the thing that's so troubling about
this particular case jesse obviously
isn't even the press is the fact that
the prosecutor was so cudgelled into
place by the press that he decided to
bring this case in the first place there
is not only no evidence that this was
not self-defense there is negative
evidence i mean his own witnesses were
testifying against the prosecution
position why he thought that he could
bring this case is beyond me unless you
just believed that he was doing it for
the media planets and uh and we'll see
if it works out for him and there he is
you see on the screen pointing
an ar-15 at the jury with his finger
actually on the trigger it's just
astounding that someone like that holds
office in this country um there's also
some snobbery at play i brought this up
earlier on our air
the press doesn't think kenosha as a
midwestern town is is worthy of
protecting they don't think kyle
rittenhouse should be out there
protecting some some stupid you know car
dealership this is flyover country right
this isn't worth for this isn't like the
hamptons getting looted this isn't
georgetown this is just small town
america who cares if it burns you can
always you know buy another car
dealership and that that snobbery
really
infected their entire posture throughout
all of their riots
that's exactly right i mean the thing to
remember about this is that it's not
just that they are angry at kyle
rittenhouse for showing up in order to
defend private property and businesses
they're angry that the cops were there
well led all of this off in kenosha
wisconsin in the first place is the fact
that they decided to to malign innocent
cops they suggested that jacob blake was
shot unjustifiably by a white police
officer on the basis of race when it
turned out that jacob blake had a had an
arrest warrant out for him for alleged
third-degree felonious sexual assault
yep and then he refused to hand himself
over to the cops and was carrying a
knife at the time and got himself shot
in the process not only did the media
play that as just another
stain on america's racial racially
charged system but joe biden called up
jacob blake kamala harris visited with
the family and this was all part of the
broader narrative which is that the
american system is racist stem to stem
to root and and that means that root and
branch and that means that that anybody
who defends any institution including i
guess a car dealership is part of that
you know they they created racial riots
with deception on the blake
case and then when the
vacuum of power was filled by rioters
and by
do-gooders
some two people were shot dead
and now they want the guy who is there
to defend the community
basically they want his life to be over
and have him rot in prison forever and
they want to lionize the pedophile and
lionize the domestic abuser it's
disgusting but we see through it you
know you watch the cnn you watch msnbc
they cut this up and they splice it up
and they masquerade it into something
it's not you watch fox you watch the
daily wire you see straight down the
middle coverage we're broadcasting the
entire trial let the audience decide for
themselves they can look at the video
they can hear the testimony and that's
what you're getting you're getting the
truth you're not getting the spin last
word ben shapiro
you know i i always tend to attribute to
stupidity rather than malice when i can
but it is impossible to watch the media
coverage and the prosecutor in this case
and not think that this is malice rather
than stupidity
let's sprinkle in a little stupidity
though though shall we i think it's i
think it's a little bit there all right
ben got the book out
good stuff thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else